a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family got your
message about Georgie okay I don't know
George is Amir's he considerably bigger
you know he's definitely bigger what's
happening to my friend are you familiar
with genetic editing someone's mutating
animals into monsters your oversized
monkey is old news
of course the wolf flies
let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't hide it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people right I do know that yeah
but that's no fun rampage only in
cinemas it's weird you like hanging out
with animals more than people yeah well
animals get me a rescue George from here
was 2 years old George never would have
survived on his own he definitely trusts
you last night George of 7 feet away 500
pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay
this morning his nine feet pushing a
thousand
what's happening to my friend are you
familiar with genetic editing the
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hell of a day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's big
mistake
I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me back
you have to evacuate Chicago
George didn't ask for this they're gonna
put him down
that's not happening
there's something in the river
I was just thinking the only thing
that's missing right now how's the giant
crocodile
[Music]